i feel like when you meet like uh
celebrities or whatever in the right
environment like it normally results in
like really positive
like if you're in the green room with
someone that normally um obviously not
everyone
can get in the green room sadly right
yeah but you know if they're in a place
where they're like comfortable
and you talk to them i find like most
people you speak to are really [ __ ]
cool
that's true most most i mean i've met
plenty of guests who have been like
yikes
yeah yeah at conventions yeah we'll go
into that yeah well we should leave them
unnamed
yeah i don't want to get called out
because that one time i punched that kid
i really don't want that getting out
once i punched that guest dude
some of the stuff i've seen guests do
you're like holy [ __ ] they're confident
doing that in front of like eight other
guests
jesus christ yeah i've seen i've seen
guests that have made like cause they're
cons you get like handlers
i've seen them like make their handlers
cry over like nothing yeah
we're all just sitting there in the room
like
okay
maybe i'll need a coffee at some point
over this weekend like i feel bad asking
you to do that
yeah yeah yeah i don't know um i feel
like one guest who and this is probably
gonna be like so like of course
i i um so when i was doing like
obviously sebastian stuff for so long
yeah okay no cause like i felt like i
learned so much right
so uh i was copying j michael tatum's
sebastian impression for so [ __ ] long
right and uh i was so worried when i met
him because i was like i'm literally
like made my
career at that point yeah i've just
copied it yeah right which could have
gone either way
you thought it could have been like the
spider-man meme like
it could have been like i [ __ ] hate
what you're doing why are you copying me
yeah doing that or it could have been
like
who are you or it could have been like
oh nice i guess i didn't expect i don't
know what i expected and uh when i met
him he was super [ __ ] nice he was
like oh you're that [ __ ] guy like
jokingly yeah yeah
and i was like okay he's cool about it
and yeah he invited me for drinks and
stuff and we met and uh
yeah one thing i learned from him is
that like he is amazing at handling like
like uh the the fans that come to him
not really i'm just getting like
sit next to him and watch him like talk
to them and like he just immediately
like changed his like atmosphere based
on who he saw who was coming near him
yeah yeah
like he just read people like
immediately and so start trying to like
copy doing that and like it's like rough
at the start but i feel like i've
learned so much from him and just
how to compose yourself how did you be
nice to people
such an [ __ ] so not only did you copy
his voice but you copied the way that
yeah
he was so willing to like like help me
out and teach me things and uh he also
like
i was like training you up like a
prodigy yeah yeah like there was a con
that i i
like wasn't going to go to and he
personally like vouched on my behalf
oh yeah this guy's good he was like you
need to get him and like really nice guy
him and his
husband brandon are both some of the
nicest ones i mean yeah
i was just about to say like the way
that brandon and i kind of
met online was a little like are you
[ __ ] on voice actors
no no not really it was like uh
so to give context like i've never met
brandon ireland yet but we follow each
other on twitter
and we've talked like he's one of the
most nicest dudes i've ever seen such a
nice guy
and i can immediately tell incredibly
intelligent he's not getting tick-tock
famous as well yeah yeah i saw
i saw but um i did this video uh i think
sometime this year it was early this
year where i asked my fans on twitter to
send me videos of them
speaking in japanese asking questions
about japanese
and then i respond or like answer their
questions or whatever and one of the
videos
was brandon and he was speaking in
the most perfect japanese i've ever
heard like his japanese is actually
perfect yeah yeah and uh in the video he
uh
he said he basically asked like so uh
i've seen videos of you in the past
kind of [ __ ] on dubs so so he's uh
that so michael and his husband are both
uh voices
yeah they're both are voice and uh
brandon used to be a professional
translator yeah he was so
hence why he's japanese yeah but in the
video in full japanese
you know very very professional japanese
he's like so um you've kind of been uh
talking ill-heartedly about uh dogs and
dumb voice actors
um so as a translator i want to know
like what is the best like what is the
solution to that
and immediately in the video you can see
immediately i was just like
i'm so sorry he had like that [ __ ] brown
enough that like [ __ ] eating grin of
like
i've i've completely won here yeah yeah
yeah i have taken the w
now i remember when i saw that on
twitter i was like good joey you have to
admit the dubs are good now
yeah so basically in the video
i was just like listen like it's not the
voice actors usually it's the voice
directors you know i did that whole
spiel yeah and luckily he was really
really cool about it and you know
because he
he said it in such a nice fashion as
well to me
he you know i couldn't help but just
being like okay you know what
i'll give you that one yeah you drop
this king like i'll give it to you
all right yeah but um yeah he's dude
like i'd love to meet him irl
oh yeah they're both super nice guys and
i mean the reason why i
speak so highly of them is because
they've just been so nice to me and so
welcoming honestly every dub
voice actor i've interacted with either
irl or not irl has been
really really nice to me considering the
fact that i had supposedly [ __ ] talked a
lot of tough voice actors
i haven't been talking the voice actors
okay just the just the product just the
dark you're just trying to deflect the
blame
please i like you deflect i liked you
guys
oh it's the director's fault meet the
director it was the production yeah it
was the production team's fault i mean
it was the audio software it wasn't toby
it was no one's fault you just had a
crunch time yeah yeah yeah i was deaf in
one ear clearly